who inspires me the most so I got a
great question from one of my youtube
viewers love you guys kids karate he
wrote in to say everyone I really look
forward to your videos but I had a
thought if you had to pick one person
who inspires you who would that be
thanks again so I love all the creative
questions that I get on YouTube I don't
think I've ever been asked this question
before so I'm happy to answer it the
person who inspires me the most is
actually a PG&E Nina he died
years ago he was the founder of Bank of
America and you might be thinking AP
Giannini a banker dude Evan come on what
are you talking about but he was a
different kind of banker and he's my
favorite entrepreneur of all time and
why I loved him is that he really
believed in the little guy he believed
in the entrepreneur so two of my
favorite stories one when he was first
getting to the banking industry he was
on the board of a bank called Columbus
savings and loans and he saw all these
immigrants come into the country who
wanted to apply for a loan but the bank
said they're too risky what we can't
give them money and he said these guys
who work hard you know they'll pay us
back we should this is a great
opportunity and they said no you know
you don't know what you're talking about
we're not gonna do it so he went and he
used to decide instead of just letting
this happen right like a lot of a lot of
people they see injustice and it just
let it happen he said no you know what
I'm gonna open up my own Bank I'm gonna
take action on this I'm gonna be the
change that I want to see in the world
and he opened his bank right across the
street from Columbus savings and loans
just to put it in their face and he
started getting all these entrepreneurs
and people who are hardworking who
didn't have a you know tons of
collateral because he believed that they
were paying back and even more powerful
story is when there was this huge fire
in San Francisco and it destroyed a lot
of the city and a lot of the banks
closed down because their banks were
burning right and people needed money
right they needed money to buy food and
to support themselves and he couldn't go
to any of the banks because they were
closed
and so EP Giannini saw this and he said
this isn't right and so he went to his
bank which was totally burnt down and he
set up two barrels and put a plank of
wood on top of it and he opened up shop
and he sat there and he'd lent money to
people who came out and he'd lent money
to people based on a look in their eye
and their handshake and he believed them
that they would pay him back are you
kidding me a look in their eye and a
handshake um does that what kind of Bank
imagine going to a bank and saying I
would like a loan I will pay you back it
doesn't happen but he became this figure
that was supporting entrepreneurs and
supporting hard-working people that that
just believing in the little guy was a
story that I don't know it resonates
with me as part of why I started this
company to help entrepreneurs and he
continued that throughout his entire
career and when Walt Disney was his
unknown crazy lunatic entrepreneur that
nobody wants support to create movies
and create Disneyland are you nuts
this is stupid nobody would want to go
to this AP Giannini was a guy who
financed him when people wanted to build
the Golden Gate Bridge everybody said
this is crazy this will never work it's
a stupid idea you're gonna lose tons of
money a PG&E was a guy who financed it
right he continued to take bets on
people and just that philosophy really
resonated with me and I loved his story
and even though he's he's passed away
for years and years it's something that
I try to remember and had a major
influence on me so he's my favorite
entrepreneur by the pick and number two
Steve Jobs to be my second buddy Pete
Jeanine in my first so great question
thank you so much for asking it for
those of you watching who inspires you I
love the seed in the comments leave the
what you have one person the one person
who inspires you the most
leave it in the comments below I'd love
to see what comes back and you guys like
this video thumbs up below
look at my face subscribe to the channel
thank you so much I'll see you soon